[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
an energy plant classified as renewable
which receives hundreds of millions of
pounds in subsidies is britain's biggest
emitter of co2 according to new analysis
shared with sky news
the un classes access to a clean healthy
and sustainable environment as a human
right
and hopeless despite hopes he'd be
attending the vatican confirms there'll
be no papal presence in glasgow for cop
26.
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
new analysis shared with sky news shows
that a government subsidised energy
plant classed as renewable is the uk's
largest single emitter of carbon dioxide
the drax plant in selby in north
yorkshire burns biomass pellets to
generate electricity for which it
receives hundreds of millions of pounds
in subsidies
but the uk and eu controversially both
exclude biomass emissions from their co2
totals
well data shared exclusively with sky
news has found that the plant emits
14.8 million tons of co2 from burning
mostly wood pellets to create
electricity which is classed as
renewable now that makes the plant the
biggest single source of carbon dioxide
in the uk
it's also the third highest emitting
plant in europe higher even than some
coal plants
but the uk excludes biomass emissions
from its total count because like the eu
it treats bio energy as immediately
carbon neutral now that's based on the
assumption that forest regrowth will
soak up the carbon again
well ember which carried out the
research says it takes too long for
bioenergy to become carbon neutral
they're relying on
the idea that the trees grow and that
stores carbon and then they burn them
and then that's that's all carbon
neutral of course what that doesn't take
into account is the enormous amount of
time it takes for trees to grow so
uh in restoring the forest it could take
50 years 100 years
and so when you take that into account
you're getting a huge pulse of emissions
into the atmosphere right now and then
maybe 50 100 years later you're reaching
carbon neutrality and obviously that's
not the time scale we need to tackle
climate change
well ember exclusively shared its report
with our climate change reporter
victoria seabrook who's here with me now
and victoria that point about timings is
key isn't it yes that's at the very
heart of the debate around biomass now
bear in mind that almost every country
in the world has agreed that we need to
cut our emissions to almost zero by 2050
if we're going to stave off the worst
impacts of climate change now that's
only 30 years time less
so if we're waiting 40 or 100 years or
more potentially to
recapture this carbon dioxide that's
released from burning biomass well a lot
of scientists are saying that's time
that we simply don't have when we need
to be cutting emissions right now and in
fact 500 scientists this year wrote to
the eu asking it to stop classing
biomass as carbon neutral and they said
that actually burning it is going to
increase global warming and therefore it
shouldn't be classed as renewable and it
shouldn't qualify for these big
subsidies and they are big sums so last
year drax received more than 800 million
pounds from the government for burning
biomass
so what are drax and the government
saying about it well they've both very
firmly defended biomass drax has said
ember's interpretation of the figures
for drax's co2 emissions is inaccurate
and completely at odds with what the
world's leading climate scientists at
the un ipcc say about sustainable
biomass being crucial to delivering
global climate targets
they said that we have reduced our
emissions by more than 90 percent in the
last decade and drax is now one of
europe's lowest carbon energy generators
and the
business and energy department they said
much the same they said we do not
recognize these figures the uk
government is committed to eliminating
our contribution to climate change by
2050 and biomass is a key element of our
plans to reach this
target so very firm there from both and
i should also just mention that
separately drax is involved with a court
case at the moment which is unrelated
that's to do with the dust that comes
from its wood pellets when they're
handled in the factory and has nothing
to do with the emissions when they're
burned so separate issues there but in
any case difficult time for drax
victoria thanks very much indeed
now the un human rights council passed a
resolution today recognizing access to a
clean healthy and sustainable
environment as a human right well dr
david boyd who's the un special
rapporteur on human rights and the
environment described the resolution as
having life-changing potential and he
joins us now live uh welcome to you
first of all just how important do you
consider this resolution to be
well this is really a historic moment
you know it's not every day that the
world recognizes a new human right so
this is a potentially life-saving
game-changing right given the face given
the fact that we face this triple-headed
global environmental crisis of climate
change loss of biodiversity and
pervasive pollution so you say it's
potentially life-saving how so
well because this resolution is a
catalyst for changes in every country in
the world it should result in countries
bringing in stronger environmental laws
and policies improving the
implementation and enforcement of those
laws and policies and it gives people a
very powerful tool a human right is a
tool that people can use to hold their
governments accountable
you said it should see governments
bringing in tighter laws is this legally
binding do they have to do that
no and i think that's important to be
perfectly clear that this is not a
legally binding or enforceable treaty
it's a resolution which is more more
akin to a political declaration but as
we saw in 2010 with the un resolution
that for the first time recognized the
right to water that was a catalyst for
incredible changes at the national level
countries changed their constitutions
they changed their legislation and most
importantly they put a greater priority
on delivering on that fundamental
promise of the human right to safe water
a lot is talked about uh in terms of
timings when we're talking about
cutting emissions and improving our
environment there isn't much time how
long do you think it could take before
countries around the world recognize
this and put it into law
oh i think this will start happening
within the next year i mean that was the
experience with the right to water
resolution that i just mentioned that it
resulted in immediate changes to
constitutions legislation and practices
on the ground and given the urgency of
the global environmental crisis it's
absolutely imperative that governments
across the world
take higher ambition in terms of their
climate action in terms of their
reducing pollution in terms of
protecting and conserving and restoring
nature and a human rights-based approach
is the most powerful way that we can do
that in an equitable and effective
fashion
and very briefly can you give us an
example of how this might be applied
absolutely so for example the world is
planning to protect 30 of the earth's
lands and waters by 2030 but we have to
do that from a rights-based perspective
to make sure that we're not throwing
people out of their homes in the process
of creating new parks and protected
areas as we have in the past so a
rights-based approach working with the
people on the ground has actually been
proven to be more effective than
traditional fortress styles of
conservation same in the climate context
where we have rights-based climate
action then we will make sure that we
aren't doing things like protecting
forests where people are living and
preventing them from earning a
livelihood in those forests
dr david boyd thanks very much indeed
thanks very much anna
now new research by wwf shows that fewer
than one in five of the uk's top
companies have published a detailed
action plan to reduce their climate
emissions to net zero the conservation
organization told us the government
won't be able to keep the uk's climate
promises without legislation forcing big
businesses to plan how they'll reach net
zero by 2050.
this report that shows us that only 19
of those top companies have got a clear
plan for action that's not enough we
need government to come forward to make
sure that we have mandatory transition
plans that align with the science we've
got the commitments let's make sure
we've got credible plans in place that
set those companies on the right
trajectory that get us on that race to
zero and make sure that we that actually
they deliver what they say they're going
to deliver i think some companies are
being very brave in terms of moving
forward and some of this we're going to
have to learn on the job for sure but
this is about the future of humanity
we've all got to step up and i it can't
just be the pr department stepping up it
needs to make sure that this is going
through the whole of business and the
consumers can feel confident
in those commitments that are going
forward we've all got to play our part
and actually a lot of companies are
crying out for this because the ones
that are leading are saying set a level
playing field let's be transparent we've
got this transparency commitment that's
coming forward in the next couple of
years but it's a bit like putting the
calories on the box of your pizza it
doesn't really have any relation to
whether you're going to eat it or your
diet plan they're two totally different
things and we need to have confidence in
this system to have green washing now
would fundamentally undermine what we're
all trying to achieve
in some of today's other climate news
pope francis will not attend cop 26 in
glasgow the vatican has confirmed that
its delegation to next month's u.n
climate change conference will instead
be headed by its secretary of state it
had been hoped the pope would attend
after he held a pre-cop 26 summit
earlier this week he joined 40 religious
leaders in issuing a joint climate
appeal to heads of state asking for
concrete solutions to save the planet
from an unprecedented ecological crisis
a study has found a lack of diversity in
climate change decision making the
year-long study in bristol which was
conducted by the city's university found
that voices of people from diverse
backgrounds make up just three percent
of discussions on climate change
findings also revealed that white men
spoke on average 64 of the time while
men from black asian or ethnic minority
backgrounds spoke for just one percent
of the time
daily meat consumption in the uk has
fallen by 17
in the past decade according to a study
published in lancet planetary health but
that reduction is not happening quickly
enough to reduce the environmental
impact of our diets
the national food strategy says meat
consumption in the uk needs to fall by
30 percent over the next 10 years to
meet sustainable farming goals
marine mucilage also known as sea snot
is causing problems for fishermen in
turkey's sea of marmara it can cause
nets to become entangled and break and
is also susceptible to bacteria that can
threaten marine environments scientists
believe that the growth of sea snot is
caused by rising sea temperatures and
human induced pollution
do stay with us coming up after the
break i'll be joined by the founder of
climate in color joycelyn london and
bruce niles the director of the climate
think tank climate imperative and we're
going to be talking about the latest
figures that indicate a lack of
diversity in climate change policy
making and also if biomass should be
viewed as a source of clean energy
that's coming up
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place for news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
overnight fog patches over central and
southern england will gradually lift to
warm sunshine it'll be cloudier
elsewhere with outbreaks of rain moving
from scotland northern ireland and the
republic into northern england and wales
skies will brighten later from the west
over ireland and northwest scotland
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high air pollution levels will be
low but isolated pockets of moderate
pollution are possible in urban areas
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news we're going to
get straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day now with the founder
of climate in color joycelyn london and
bruce niles the executive director of
climate imperative so welcome to both of
you good to see both
so first of all biomass power accounts
for around 12 percent of the uk's
electricity making it the country's
second largest source of renewable
energy the government says it's helped
to dramatically reduce the uk's use of
coal and is key to achieving net zero
emissions but some scientists argue that
burning wood for power is not a
sustainable solution so should we view
biomass as a clean energy source
bruce to you first of all and let me
just
forgive me if i'm wrong
correct me if i'm wrong the theory
behind biomass is that you harvest
forests sustainably then you burn the
wood but then if you also plant new
trees they will absorb roughly the same
amount of carbon that's being released
from the burning of the wood and
its advocates would say that makes it a
clean renewable energy source what's
your take
that was the state of the science couple
decades ago today the notion that we
would cut down trees here in america put
them on a ship burning a lot of oil ship
them to the uk
burn them in
a giant power plant and assume that is
helpful for the climate
that is not where the science is today
the science says we're in code red
situation for humanity
and even the prime minister has his
tagline for how we solve the climate
coal cars cash and trees he's not
talking about burning trees he's talking
about planting trees which is a critical
part of what we need to do globally
to solve the climate crisis and so this
is just an outdated holdover from when
we didn't know better but but this does
involve planting trees doesn't it to
replace the carbon so
why is there a problem well the two
things and you mentioned at the top of
the hour one is that it takes a long
time for trees to grow back
um and then secondly the energy involved
in shipping them across the country
cutting them down in the first place uh
it doesn't make any science-based sense
to continue to do that when we're trying
to get to zero as fast as humanly
possible
and joycelyn the uk and the eu class
biomass as renewable and in fact just to
remind us the government does say that
biomass is a key element of plans to to
reach net zero targets what are your
thoughts on this
i mean i think i'd have to second what
bruce has said um we need to really
reconsider what we mean by sustainable
and as the science has proved this isn't
really sustainable um when trees are
such an important part of our strategy
to get who net zero and i'm not a
biofuel expert but i think another
important thing we need to keep in mind
is that
um kind of at the same time as a climate
crisis we have a biodiversity crisis and
planting trees just to be cut down again
does nothing for our biodiversity
nothing for natural ecosystems which are
equally as important and we can't just
keep focusing on this net zero kind of
calculation down to zero because it's
not a true
um kind of signifier of our progress
bruce you you don't think the biomass is
should be classed as a renewable source
of energy
what
what technology might help you change
your mind if there was the technology to
capture the carbon released when the
wood is burnt
would that make a big difference and how
far away are we from that
so as jocelyn said we're trying to solve
several crises at the same time one is
climate and the other is the ecological
crisis
um we need trees for both both to pull
carbon out of the atmosphere and also to
make sure there is homes for
a lot of wildlife that's teetering on
the edge of extinction so again this
this makes no sense and um the the path
forward is how do we phase out biomass
now that the uk is very close to being
done with coal
the path ahead is investing in offshore
wind and solar and all the things that
are allowing the country to make great
progress on coal now to make the same
progress on phasing out biomass it'll be
interesting to see how this argument
plays out
on both sides but let's move on to our
next topic shall we because as we heard
earlier in the show new research by the
university of bristol suggests climate
change discussions are still dominated
by white men and it's something that
environmentalists and campaign groups
have come under fire for in the past so
is the climate change movement
unrepresentative and joycelyn this comes
from a year-long study in bristol
doesn't it it found that
voices of ethnically diverse people make
up just three percent of discussions on
climate change decision making
you have founded a company called uh
climate in color i think one of the
things you're trying to do is try to
make sure that conversations are more
diverse so are you surprised by this
finding
no of course no i'm not surprised by
this finding because the inequality that
we see in other
parts of life other industries is not
any different in the climate space but i
think that a key thing to keep in mind
is
where we are kind of looking at these
discussions because through my work um
people of color women and people from
marginalized communities are actually on
the front line of these issues on the
front line of the effects of these
issues but also at the front line and
leading action in many ways so when we
say that there's a lack of diversity in
climate change discussions i think we
need to think about where those
discussions are happening because it
seems like there's a huge
disparity between on the ground
grassroots and front line um
representation of marginalized
communities and then um sort of
institutional organizational and
governmental conversations um and i
think there is where we see a huge issue
bruce what's the situation like in the
states
uh it's exactly as you're describing um
in the uk which is um
we have historically made a lot of
decisions that are by a very small part
of society and we now know and we're
seeing policies begin to put in place to
actually address this so in california
for example
recently a law was passed that no longer
can the boards of corporations be all
men and all white
and so how do we open up decision making
so as jocelyn said particularly for
people who are the most affected we will
make better decisions
and more durable decisions if we're
involving the very people who are
impacted by
um being on the front lines of this
climate crisis
what do you make joycelyn of steps like
that how do you think we should address
this
well um i think there's a really
important quote by thomas sankara which
i can paraphrase but
the inclusion of marginalized
communities is not one that's out of
charity it's because it is a real
necessary basis for a kind of triumph
and success in overcoming the climate
emergency um these people are not just
victims they're not people that we have
to include because of charity they're
actually
so creative and so dedicated i'm out of
in a lot of um times necessity um so
really our success will be built on
inclusion i mean it's it is a necessity
rather than a sort of charitable action
and justin a very quick thought on cop
26 coming up how confident are you that
a diverse range of voices will be heard
there
i think um that that will depend on
which zone you're in
i think the blue zone not so much um
there are huge barriers um from the uk
home office and from vaccines and all of
these different barriers uh financial
barriers
um in the green zone uh there are a huge
amount of events we've got cop26
coalition doing such amazing work so
many activist groups are going to be
there and that's where the real
diversity is going to stand out in my
opinion okay joycelyn london and bruce
niles we must leave it there we're out
of time good to see you both thanks very
much
indeed thank you
do stay tuned with us here on